Philadelphia Pennsylvania baby have we
got good news for you we just added a
second show down there at the Fillmore
for December yeah gang you guys were
awesome the Army garbage came correct we
sold out the first show four months
before the freaking show so we added
another let's do it again baby tickets
on sale right now at Ru garbage.com
tickets on sale right now for all other
cities on the state trashy Tour on our
website links in the description get
them do it gang before we get to the
episode let's talk about mint mobile
Baby Got It Best in the bid shout out to
Mint mobile we all know inflation is
everywhere it will not stop it keeps on
it coming thankfully mint mobile can
give you a little break from that
inflation by saving a little money on
your phone bill yeah mint mobile let you
order from your home and save a ton with
Wireless plans start at just 15 bucks a
month order today at mintmobile.com
garbage that's mintmobile.com
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that if they're
going to be classy yeah or if they're
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
hoodies in the new edition she's out
doing a little back to school shopping
okay taking some classes this fall but
is she karate but still yeah
got him my co-host is coming at you from
across the table he is the CEO of Ru
garbage she's great on the weekends
he'll let his hair down or hang out but
come Monday morning baby it's all about
business sure give it up for Kim Jong
Ryan everybody didn't we take yesterday
off
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe
review subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com garbage also I was I was
told by uh by one of the homies to
mention it's an app ah of course people
don't know what's in that they might not
know it's an app so you download your
phone all the contents available there
you sign up you get bonus episodes ayg
hard hard feelings all of the
goal videos we've done just all the
bonus content the Disney The Cribs check
it the out gang how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the old magic man very
funny Chicago comic by way of the back
woods in North Carolina grew up on the
farm down there with a big old huh give
it up for T-Bone disgruffins Toby
McMullen and I heard there was a pig on
the farm what's up dude how's that buddy
like that fire engine that's good come
on let's go
my balls ah yes dude Dog Days this
summer we're bringing it home it's about
to get cold and gloomy but for now it's
sunny and beautiful I love it I love it
every minute I love it man I love the
end of the summer I love
it that humidity starts to taper
off a little bit you can smell and feel
the fall and like like a Saturday
afternoon it'll get a little bit crisper
and you can like feel it coming
birds are starting up the
Phillies are gonna be in the postseason
it's gonna be sure plus you see
those back to school signs popping up
and you're like ah not me enjoy
that I used to love that though no
it's cool the first day of school I
loved yeah what yeah you got fresh gear
you get the sheet of broads who who grew
up over the summer who don't love that
huh but yeah find yourself
coming you know early November you're in
the thickness oh I hated it but like
fresh pencils and and binders and the
book bags nice just look at it just
looking at your manila folder going I
can't wait to crumple all this up yeah
plus there was never a grow grocery
store order like the first week of
school
it was like Cason I'm correct or don't
come at all oh man loaves of white bread
as high as the eye could see it really
started trailing off around
mid-september yeah that once that first
pack of Fruit Roll-Ups was gone
it was like it was every man for himself
until Christmas I know man really Jamie
up love it uh-huh love it
um but that being said also got a huge
announcement we are announcing our
second show in Philadelphia baby at the
Fillmore we sold the first one out four
months ahead of time gang shout out to
the Army of garbage we
love you so tickets are on sale I
believe tomorrow we sell now promo code
garbage get them the link will be in the
description a whole nine yards pick them
up gang
we're closing out the ear down here in
Philadelphia out there Foley yeah it's
gonna be nice come see us
um I did something this weekend
Jesus Christ
sometimes you just turn into Channel 3
News give it up for Chuck chuckerson
over here
Chuck Chuckers it's all right
hey I did something over the weekend
gang
yeah I would have hope so I hope you
just lay there in your in your I
did a lot I did a lot okay I will
tell us about it
I don't want to yeah
I did a lot I did something this weekend
all right tell us I did a lot I did a
lot nine people were shot yesterday
you're going over your weekend
it's a thrill on fire and you're talking
about the goddamn short I'm Chuck Chuck
I had another top story tonight I did
some stuff this weekend more at 10. who
had a shrimp quesadilla this weekend
I'll tell you
I cleaned out my refrigerator
wait we should why did you save this for
a normal broadcast we should have kicked
into the onto the programming
just in it should be live
streaming this no I love how clean
ing my refrigerator is just fat guy eats
all the eggs really cleaned out my
fridge man there was some real suspect
items in there too oh yeah it's a real
good feeling that's why that's why I
brought it up it's a real good feeling
to clean out that fridge sure get the
get the Clorox out bleach it all down
put your then put your fresh produce in
there like you're cleaning up a murderer
I know oh yeah get the yellow tape out
and everything throwing lie
The First 48 minutes gotta get that done
yeah a lot of hair in there there's a
lot of hair in there okay on the bottom
underneath the Crispers I get you which
I wanted to ask you do you guys use that
the Crispers do you are you are you
compart are you Department Savvy like
does the lunch meat go in the lunchroom
because if his refrigerator is plugged
in to be honest with you I would be real
definitely no light I'd be real
surprised if that thing was running
right now I got I got like five of every
type of condiment and I don't know which
one's still good yeah I'll be in there I
was gonna break I I have I have
something for you by the way
I brought you back a bottle of hot sauce
ooh yeah I was down down in Sea Isle
city known for their hot sauce
okay would you steal it from the diner
you were at I was gonna but then they
were like oh they sell it across the
street at the Acme it's a local place
Hank sauce okay awesome I think you're
gonna like it sick I'm sucks yeah
um yeah we don't mind well we don't use
anything my wife's old my wife's cookie
patooky is the butter in the butter
thing for the butter that's in the
fridge the the stock of but the surplus
of butter usually is I used to put a lot
of drugs in there and the butter thing
that was always if you keep your wee
there was a while where like you know
keeping your weed fresh was like a thing
everybody always jars you jar it that
was like yeah put it in a jar and stick
it in there yeah I don't know no I was
never a big reefer head I did
keep my beers in there though shout out
to it
um we're all over the place it's chaos
it drives me nuts there's things
in there there's like a half drank can
of Lacroix there's a it's like
it drives me nuts half a can of
soda in the fridge that's insane to me
you should be taken out back and
shot it's insane until you roll in there
at two o'clock in the morning dying a
thirst and you have a full can of soap
like I don't understand the half a can
gets colder you say it sure but there's
also other options as well if that's
your listen if you're in a position
where you're saving a half a can of
Cola and that's all you got when
you're coming home you're jammed up
which I'm saying sure that's when you
appreciate it the most you know what I
did find in there that I dipped in a
little bit too much on the you know
sometimes you go you open the door you
don't really see thing you don't really
see really what's there sure because
there's so much stuff man there was a
thing a Tropicana sitting there
a big boy that must have been just
sitting there for weeks I don't even
remember buying it okay and untouched
screaming cold what's going on in there
you're missing a half gallon of
shot but you guys got inventory issues
Jesus Christ in the back uh yeah that is
a good feeling clean it clean any any
sort of uh forward momentum cleaning
anything such in a right tone yeah which
I do respect I got something
uh I was I was over at the uh at the new
uh the new home uh Casa de Kip the casa
de Kippy out there in any Town USA
suburbanite
um and we're having uh some people come
and do work right we're getting quotes
done for work quotes Quotes come by and
give a quote and I don't know these
people go for the Hard Sell right they
want to come in and they want to they
want to close ass she's a sucker like
you standing there
um what we uh we had one this morning it
was an early am
it was uh 8 30 8 30 appointment and
that's how they do it they come out and
they take a look first yeah they give
you the whole rig and we'll roll the
whole nine yards whatever might not
banging over the head sure yeah my whole
thing is what is the as a purchaser as a
as the as the homeowner as the guy being
sold
what is my requirement
refreshment wise wardrobe wise oh that's
why I have to uh they really came to the
right place do I have to it's also it's
gonna be Adobe I just told you I found
orange juice
I thought I was a gentleman like
yourself I figure you know what the
where you got the OJ ah I'm just saying
or it's early it's ER I'm not a morning
guy it's an early am
also it's like you're selling me on
there I'm not trying to impress you I'm
not putting on a 3p suit I get that you
probably should shower and or brush your
teeth you gotta brush your teeth splash
some water in your face I think a pair
of basketballs whatever you slept in
unless it's something naughty well I
mean I don't know it's hard to counter
in a mask
[Laughter]
the guy took me to the cleaner bet me
over if you catch my drift take the anal
beads out at least he's as great as a
Tuesday
um my whole thing yeah so it's like
what'd he show up in well can I ask
where you were getting done
uh yeah we're looking at getting our
floors done floor's done it's a national
company there's a small operation not a
small operation not a small operation
not a not a I don't know if it's
National it's a corporation it's not
Gary's floor was he in a suit or did he
have the unit like the Izod and the
khakis
yeah but not great okay like he could
have been
he's a regular guy I don't think those
clothes were clean this morning if I was
getting those pants those pants didn't
have a crease in them I'll tell you that
gotcha what were you wearing uh pair of
Nike
shorts okay uh the shirt I slept in with
a neck that looked like I was in a
wrestling match that's cool and about a
half a hard on if I'm being honest good
looking guy I was I was semi bricked up
and you're I don't did you just roll out
of bed for the most part yeah that's no
good that's no idea that's no good for
you you're in groggy mode he's gonna go
in there and see this guy's a
idiot you know what the
leaves with the dog yeah it's mine
putting floors on the ceiling I felt
when he walked in and saw me he was like
this guy don't have any money like he
did he was like hey
your parents home he's your Handler here
yeah it was go get your mother uh I do
think in a perfect world you should you
shouldn't be in what you wore that's I
mean that's insane I just think it
should be fresh and alert with a half a
cup of coffee I did have half a cup of
coffee did you offer him a cup I didn't
you didn't do you offer him anything uh
my wife did okay yeah she goes do you
want anything he said no I'm okay
anything
do you want a cup of coffee or water or
anything okay that's different which we
didn't have any water to offer me he was
getting a glass of water it's fine uh
it's a burbs sure clean and we had like
a half of the half of very half of pot
of coffee that was you know it was like
a Jiffy Lube it was two three
days old we got a half an avocado in
here
split it with you couple slices of bacon
we can throw on for you if you want uh
yeah it was tough I do think as I was
doing I'm like this is a dirt baggy
thing you should be presentable I would
say honestly yes you're conducting
business what you're wearing doesn't
matter I disagree no I think what what
I'm saying is what you had on was fine
but you just got to freshen up you got
to be fresh you shouldn't be conducting
business in the clothes you slept in
you're not conducting yes I am business
that's business that's a business
meeting is it you're getting some
plywood put in your house I
don't know why you're demeaning the wood
I'm getting installed
it ain't Pine I'll tell you that what
kind of fake flooring you're getting put
in that that's what everybody's nice
Trap House you got
going down uh meet me in the Trap baby
um where did you conduct this said
meeting this business meeting at kitchen
counter at the kitchen counter The Only
Furniture we have is the bars there's no
there are stools yeah so you haven't
have a seat
yeah he was walking around checking the
place out gonna play scoping probably
casing The Joint yeah what's he gonna
steal the bar stools there ain't nothing
in there gang uh but I do think as I was
doing it I was like this isn't right I
understand oh you got to freshen up and
change the bird
uh she changed into her day clothes the
day closed yeah sure I think she
showered too workout stuff or like like
uh
no it wasn't workout stuff I don't know
why you're prying into this he really
breezed over what I was wearing and you
now you want the Deets on this
huh you little horndog ah it's the
Lululemon
uh yeah just some sort of like day
dressy type the both of you should be
doing is to really get the upper hand in
the negotiating you guys should both be
matching both be wearing the same thing
when they walked pretty good look like
real freaks also give him the smallest
chair put him on like an ottoman or
something that goes without saying real
power move yeah I had a buddy make them
stand on the other side of the screen
door growing up we don't know you
growing up my buddy anytime he needed to
ask his dad for like anything or like he
would sit in his dad's office his dad
had this huge luxurious leather
chair and he'd make him sit on like a
little tree stump because Dad would wait
his dad would make him sit on the little
tree I thought you meant he flipped it
on his dad somehow spins around here
I don't care if you pay the bills
this is my house I need weed dude
yeah it did it did fail it I it felt not
it felt very uncouth what I was doing
you're an uncouth guy I'm an uncouth guy
I didn't know I'm learning new money he
wasn't happy with he wasn't thrilled
which with what what you were wearing
I think he was just like oh he walked
into a house with no furniture and um
you've been here five years
so what's the word can I ask
uh yeah you're going with him we're
waiting to see I don't think we're gonna
go with it you're gonna do it there's
more of this is more of a hard feeling
zest thing the the whole operation of it
sure that's a um uh well no he came in
about double the the rough budget we
were we'll see on time he was late he
was late that's when I said you you
get my I did have a tuck song
yeah I changed back into what I wore uh
no he was 15 minutes late I think all
you got to do is not have sleepers in
your eyes and uh offer the guy a cup of
coffee or a bottle of water
I think that's yeah now there's more of
uh I think there I think there's a high
you're also your wardrobe level is lower
than
is lower than most I feel Toby if
somebody was coming over your house are
you talking to me or Toby you oh
you want to be rude would you well
first of all it's you're talking to two
no offense we're losers I don't know
what to do when somebody shows up I know
but you're yeah I I understand
and who do you think is coming to give
Toby a quote
a shroom guy
I mean what do you put a pair of pants
on when a shroom guy comes lit that's
that's all I'm saying you put a pair
ready to make a purchase right now we're
gonna feel in a couple other offers and
then we'll get I have two other guys
coming in
they're both just sitting on the couch
like a waiting room filling out the
paperwork I'm saying it's not like
Time Warner's coming to fix
something where you're like yeah it's
over there like this is like an
appointment set and you know a money is
being transaction there's a baby oh not
today there was it he was like hey you
want to do a deposit a deposit buddy
kick the rocks out front I ain't got the
out of here today yeah he goes so
what are we gonna have to do to get this
I just met did he get you one of those a
little bit well it's a bigger race
there's more issues running in the house
I bought kind of stinks there's a lot of
issues with it uh
laughs
um so we uh it's it was good it's going
to be more than we anticipated
[Laughter]
according to this guy who doesn't know
what he's talking about ooh it's always
more than you anticipated but he it was
so much more than we Auntie he was like
listen man I get like he didn't even go
for the clothes to be honest with you he
was like this is he like he was like I'd
be an if I tried to close you on
this today being how high it was it was
dumb because it was so much work to do a
lot of work to be done a lot of extra
work that thing you know the the
ballpark the original low ball
did it is listen pal your foundation's
all marshmallow I don't know what to
tell you I would assume that you've
never not received anybody at your home
not wearing like shorts and maybe maybe
not a shirt no I don't know I would
never not have a shirt on that's crazy
not have a shirt on to a guy like when
they came in when you had that little
problem a few months ago when they came
in to give you a long time quote on that
and they were shed bugs
bed bugs two years ago what the are
you talking about yeah
controlling that thing that happened two
days ago you know that horrible thing
I'm going to allude to oh let me just
really paint a horrible picture of your
living situation I thought that's what
you're supposed to be doing here
wait am I in the wrong show
how did you receive that guy when he
came in to give you an estimate what's
up how did you receive that guy covered
in blood with a knife in my mouth dude
what the are you talking about
we're in a Ghillie suit they told me
there'd be more of you whatever grab a
grab a knife and get in here dude jump
in the water or tanking jump that
clipboard and pick up a weapon son
yeah welcome to the Soldier yeah
huh oh God I'm all over the place over
here I'm all thumbs today okay let's
talk about that Helix baby shout out to
him talk about Helix mattresses where
not only a couple of spokes but we're
also a couple of clients I've been
snoozing on that thing for a few months
got the California gang no big deal and
they're having a big Labor Day weekend
blowout sale we're talking 25 off from
older mattresses look out Hachi Machi
they got 20 20 unique mattresses in
their lineup including once for Big and
Tall sleepers shout out to the big man
mattress made just for kids shout out to
new guy Luke everyone in the family can
get the rest they need just take the the
Helix sleeve quiz takes two minutes to
get matched with the perfect match based
on the factors like your height
preferred sleeping position whether you
tend to overheat I run a little hot
myself they do sides too what side do
you see I know they're doing great do
great stuff over there two minutes leave
quiz get a perp get the best sleep of
your life with a two-minute sleep quiz
we've been staping I've been sleeping on
for years they're fantastic I love them
Can't Get Enough best man I'll only ever
sleep bought a helix mattress I show up
to a hotel I ain't got a helix I take my
bags I get the out of there go find
a healing's mattress uh no matter which
mattress is your match with every Helix
has their hybrid design which combines
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base and premium foam layers on top
Helix is offering 25 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners in honor of Labor Day baby
shout out to it go to helixsleep.com
garbage and use the code Helix partner
25 that's helixsleep.com garbage code
Helix partner 25 this is their best
offer yet it won't last long with Helix
better sleep starts out though it can't
let's talk about that box awesome oh
baby the hype is real from the good
people at bespoke post gang we love him
and death he gets something cool showing
up every month talking about cool dog
cool guy stuff you got outdoor grilling
stuff you got grooming stuff it's
absolutely fantastic do yourself a favor
if you want to show off in front of your
friends get that box awesome yeah each
box includes curated items from the best
small Brands around the world ship
directly to you easy peasy takes all the
guesswork out is this cool is this cool
boom they pack it up they don't every
month that's how I get all my cool guy
I got knives I got cocktail stuff I
got grilling stuff I got camping stuff
indoor stuff outdoor stuff whatever you
need they got it uh get getting started
is easy take the quiz at box of
awesome.com and your answers will help
them pick the right box for you I'm an
Outdoorsman myself you know that about
me that's why I get all the cool knives
sent my way
I like the cocktail stuff I bet you did
this little Shaker uh each box is valued
at 70 bucks plus your only but you'll
only pay a fraction of the price get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com go garbage
do it gang uh I do think you should have
shoes you know companies coming over you
should put on shoes all right you're a
bozo what do you want you're the one
that did it you stink the guy tried to
charge a triple in the house thanks
I'm trying to help you out saying don't
sweat it you're the guy with the chat
yeah no but I'm also saying for the
people out there as a as somebody who's
learning this I am sure that they
answered the door wearing clothes
they're probably on their way to work
like normal people uh-huh you stink okay
that's not nice I think of a very
average
man was the guy curious what you were
doing at home in the middle of the day
no he didn't he didn't hit the Powerball
huh Mega Millions a thousand for life
made a thousand for life all right that
keeps you Ricky oh that keeps your feet
on the ground baby I don't think it is
but I always thought they did like every
Friday you get a check for a Jihad but I
don't think it's that oh they oh really
I would want that oh of course and I
would want a drug dealer you just spend
it all and make it back I would want to
have to go and pick it up I gotta make a
stop real quick oh yeah pick up some
quiche a little bit of ghee over
there where do you pick that up
Pennsylvania State Lottery oh you go to
the office I assume
it'd be nice if you went to the place
where you bought the ticket like that
guy owed you a Jihad would be awesome he
roll into like a Sev or something but
eventually that would turn
ugly oh yeah sure get you coming back
and stick up kids yes
every Friday same thing
put it on my yeah it's all right
uh but all that aside gang we got a gosh
darn Family episode uh when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your garbage
questions on the air it's just the best
way to do it and boy do we have some
doozies this one's from J hard shout out
to you ten dollar homie never have one
red have you ever been dropped off at a
hospital
that's bad I never thought of that yeah
I hadn't dropped off yeah I have why
um Senior Week class of 94 wissahick and
Trojan shooting heroin into my brain we
got uh we got a house for two weeks down
in Ocean City only made it one but had
the house for two weeks sure
I don't know how
I
somehow
got the worst case of poison ivy on my
face that I've ever had and I hadn't
been in the woods in weeks
and almost been a real Ladies Man way
down it started itching real bad and
dude by the next day I'm telling you my
whole face was covered like whole face
swollen covered dying
um and a lot of your homies hang out
with you because Gary was getting all
up drinking a party and they
dropped me off huh
wait yeah how do you get poison ivy on
your face I don't know gets on your
hands and you spread it it's very
spreadable and you're you're a
face-touching guy
yeah maybe I don't know we could never
figure it out
never figure it was only on your face
only on my face
man that is a mystery only a Foley could
create yeah only on my face oh only on
your phone only on my face there was
none on my hands none on my feet no it
was only on my face
I'm telling you it was crazy oh man I
didn't I I only ever had it bad like
normal kid like would get it whatever
once every couple of years as a kid gave
me a shot uh dude this this kid that was
allergic to it that I grew up with Joey
G was allergic to like horrible and dude
his legs
I'll never forget the sight of his legs
dude he's like are you sure you want to
see it I'm like yeah wait you
got a bad case of sumac let me see it
dude his legs look like the Toxic
Avenger it was horrible Oozy
like dude there was like pulse it was
pulsating yeah I'd get that too I'm
gonna go home what are you doing in
school well send the work to the crib
uh Poison Ivy sucks oh
sucks yeah I haven't had I mean I think
I only probably had a handful of times
and he put the calamine lotion on a pink
calamine lotion sucks this guy gave me a
shot of something yeah
all right
no more brown sugar
get me that OJ out of the fridge too
yeah man we did something that was
really fat with oatmeal when we were
kids we always put oh well I ate it out
of the tub yeah no my mom and dad always
put butter in it there's always a pad of
butter in our oatmeal I don't know if
that's a normal thing or not I don't
know butter a little sugar a little
brown sugar it's a little cinnamon we
were never big oatmeal fam huge oatmeal
family at the Foley's apples and
cinnamon Quaker Oats instant ah never
nice I think it was there maybe I didn't
eat it maybe my brother and said I just
don't remember it even being around that
much to consist it's like baby food to
me I can't with it
um I ever drop you off at the hospital
no no I can imagine your dirtbag's
buddies doing that what rolled me out
like a gunshot victim no dude yeah I
have gone to the vet to get a
knife take him to the hospital and you
call a lawyer okay yeah I'm more of a
solve my injuries than the CVS kind of
guy a little super glue and some
bandages I noticed that you don't you
don't what would it take to go to the
hospital what's up like I would need to
see bone bone yeah or a very loud pop
it's got to be like excruciating paint
yeah it's got to be something really
like you figure yeah but like cuts and
scrapes and no one's going to the
hospital for that I went further
I want the emergency room for a tick one
time
I had a tick on my arm why'd you go to
the emergency room because I was
freaking out
I was about 12 found it after the shower
made Patty take me over to the emergency
room thought for sure I wasn't leaving
don't you just burn that off or
something he just pulled it off tweezers
yeah he just pulled it off he's got to
get the head right because sometimes you
pull the body off and the head stays in
there and barrows in I was petrified do
you ever see them on dogs where they get
like real they look like real plump
they look like they're about to
explode look like corn nuts yeah yeah I
I hate Texas my neighbor's dog had
that I was like petting them like what
the get the off my property
with this
on your place
ticks everywhere as we're doing flooring
in the backyard take that all out
you want the whole backyard Kyle yeah
I'm afraid I got a buddy's afraid of
ticks
uh all right this one's from we'll see
first time long time you eating the salt
at the bottom of a bag of prezis
yeah you're eating all of the Salt Lick
the Finger press it down on it yeah
that's pure yeah are you going back in
I'll do it once yes oh yes if I still
got soda left
real yes
but you know what's you know what that's
you know an animal great for that
is the little pretzel the little yellow
box of pretzels that's different that's
that's very granular salt that's all
right sure and that's all in the package
that's a self-serving sure but bottom of
the bag in a big bag of pretzels like a
banger rolled gold or hers or suck on my
finger how do you feel about guys who do
the little bit of salt on their beer
what's that who are those guys yeah it's
like trillions or something cool what
are you hanging out with old Florida
dudes love putting a little salt on
they're on the beer yeah it's something
with the head it gives it a head or it
takes the head away take it away where
are they getting assault from on the on
the bar top like table salt
I think
I think the lime or something was
originally for flies wasn't it like it
was so like the the salt and the lime
some flies don't fly near your beer I
think oh it helps with the bitterness so
if you have like a really strong like
double IPA or some why I'm ordering
it for the bitterness
what country clubs are you hanging out
at okay I don't like it either man I
thought we were gonna trash these
yeah I don't know I mean if I
was at the bar My Buddy started putting
salt in his beer we're done
hey pass me the salt I would like to
have my own little pepper shaker a
little pepper
bloodies
I like a little like a pan the only time
I've seen it was uh in uh Owen not Owen
Wilson Luke Wilson and
Royal tannenbaums he was a big Bloody
Mary guy and he always had a little
pepper shaker well you know for like
three bucks you can get a pepper shaker
yeah check it out it's the barrier to
entry isn't that hard see how much these
floors cost on this personality and a
lime wasn't the Flies uh it was the with
the rest they're metal caps and they
would get rusty so then you'd use the
lime to wipe the rust away there you go
I don't think it's very disinfectant no
I hate a rusty bottle
like when you get a rusty bottle of beer
one like the the bottle you can taste
the bottle sure a little bit I feel like
old buds or something like Bud Heavies
you can get that seal breaks or
something
Jam you up I feel like I haven't had one
in a long time but back in the day back
when I was a wee lad
um all right let's see uh this one's
from Toody's step nephew uh is it
garbage if your dad opens up the Buffalo
Wild Wings app every time he drives by
the restaurant so he can check in and
get rewards points there you go that's
game in the system what does that do wow
I think if you Dr if you're outside and
you can log in it probably checks that
you're it registers that you're at a
Buffalo Wild Wings so you get points
probably for like every 10 check-ins man
or something never been
don't know I don't think I've ever been
maybe on the Intel I've heard
different things oh I've been in an
airport so that's not a fair assessment
I haven't been to a stand-alone buff do
you like giant glasses of flat beer and
mediocre wings and chicks with tits too
small to work at Hooters come on down to
B-Dubs I don't mind those three things
those are all right quite the
endorsement yeah
we say we get out of here head to one
um it's uh it's very like around us it
would be like Miller's Ale House is
that's like an East Coast chain Miller's
Ale House wasn't I just out of Millers
he went down in uh Orlando I think we
went to a Millers oh yeah Millers is all
right sure yeah it's a it's just like a
Applebee's type thing but Buffalo Wild
Wings is big on their sports right don't
they have like a bajillion there's like
a million TVs yeah I think it's like a
Millers at all in what sense
it's completely different
I think it's like a wall of TVs and a
bunch of like sitting bars
something like that and the things that
they serve fried food and flat beer to
people sure that's what I mean it's the
same I don't mean architecturally it's
the same that's what I thought I know
the floor plan of these goddamn
restaurants I don't know
um yeah no it's the same I'm it serves
the same clientele guys who are one
boneless wings and a
Frosty Brew
I don't love the boneless wing whoa nah
same whoa this is you love it because
it's a chicken nugget it's a chicken
tender I never said it wasn't
why are you yelling at me I wasn't a
place in Philly one time which I'm going
to mention this to you the where it was
just like little after hours place in
Rittenhouse Square it was real Swanky it
was real nice
the pen and pencil no no no this is real
nice
they took they're taped out of the
boneless wing really bothered give me
what it almost just seemed like you were
like they're delicious you no I'm
like a nugget it's a nugget I never this
is what I'm upset is it a chicken
nuggets like chicken nuggets I'm
gonna tell you something I don't think
it's a wing it's a chicken nugget and
sauce which is all right chicken nuggets
coated in sauce though and they'd lose
something but listen this this place is
different than a chicken nugget this
place this place Toby
trying to get this out for two minutes
here yeah that's right hey tell us that
one time in the 80s you had
chicken fingers let's go
the tell me what they used to do is
oh they dipped them in here they would
take a regular wing and they would go in
and they would positionally cut out the
bone and then kind of close it back up
together and then fry that so you could
just pop the whole Wing in your mouth
and it was an actual Wing those were
awesome that's not a boneless chicken
wing that is exactly not the ones you
order by definition but I mean that's a
very that's the real deal you're eating
chicken nuggets soaked in Buffalo sauce
okay so hear me out I'll tell you what's
not bad though Buffalo calamari that'll
blow your brains out shout out to the
order for now yes you you take that you
take that surgically bone removed Wing
right yeah you put a thin slice of
jalapeno and some cheese in there now
you've got a chicken wing jalapeno
popper yeah
where are you at Buffalo huh Wild Wings
how are we not turning all of this gear
off to go Patton the greatest idea
that's ever happened on this podcast
seems like a lot of work but we're not
the ones doing it man we're just doing
it
to our wing guy I'm not gonna have you
doing prep work you're telling me we
don't you tell them you can't get a wing
guy ah sure I'll work the fryer though
I'll tell you that
golden brown Foley over here
come out Chris real nice
yeah do we change the oil no that's
where the flavor is yeah I don't mind
that no I don't I everyone like you good
you should have more rears yeah sure
yeah but there is a place
uh it was on one of those Burger uh
shows where they did like the best
burgers or whatever there is a place
somewhere where they have remnants of
the oil from like the 1900s they just
keep adding to it oh I got you you know
what I'm talking about and they say
that's what I think it's for their onion
rings or something they probably yeah
they strain it or do something and they
add that back into so it's like still
conceptually there's point zero zero one
percent of it's from the 1920s that's
all right all right I don't mind they go
to like a a bar rescue or
whatever all those kitchen shows
like this is disgusting and I'm looking
at it like drop a couple of
boneless chicken tendys in there let's
get after let's do the
mozzarella stick test first yeah before
we start throwing accusations and
screaming it people you can
clean the walking all you want
leave that fryer later alone they got
bigger problems
oh yeah a big fan of a dirty fryer
sign me up uh all right this
one's from Joe is it garbage to refer to
putting something in the microwave is
nuking it or zapping it no but that's
yeah
three minutes zap it I don't think I
ever said zap it
we said Zappa but nuke it for sure yeah
yeah nuke real quick yeah
it is trashy though
sure yeah but put it in the microwave I
mean I think there's a different way to
nobody says that yes of course the guy
with that accent doesn't own a microwave
no kid nuke it yeah yeah nuke that for a
couple minutes you know what's real
classy is now they have those microwaves
that look like drawers in the real fancy
new kitchens those things I don't know
that wait dude what are you talking
about look like drawers yeah it's like
built into the countertop it's like a
drawer that slides out you place it in
and then it's real futuristic yeah I
think I've seen that it's for hot people
who never use their microwave yeah you
gonna get something like that
uh probably not you got a garbage
disposal yeah you do they took the
microwave
yeah it's not a apartment they
take the microwave no I don't think so
everybody they do you don't leave the
microwave when you when you when you
move everybody that's come over has said
I listen you've also never bought a
house I don't I haven't bought a house
the first time everybody has come over
said it's weird that they took the
microwave without why would you want
their money without telling you because
it's a it's a technically was it mounted
in in the thing yeah
oh it was above the stove not
necessarily no of no it was on uh in the
cabinet
and there's an inside the kitchen
cabinet it wasn't like one that's under
the like a sits on the
table was it wait was it just sitting in
that cabinet I don't know I didn't see
it it's gone what the I don't know
hey loose brackets uh I don't know you'd
want to get a new one though would you
have kept it I don't know I don't I mean
yeah if it matched the kitchen sure if
it was all the same setup now I
gotta I got a wonky uh
microwave hmm no I think that goes it
makes sense to me in an apartment's one
thing yeah well we're not talking about
an apartment typically the seller
includes all kitchen appliances in the
home sale including the refrigerator
oven dishwasher and microwave if it's
built in yeah if it's built in it seemed
built in apparently it wasn't I mean it
wasn't a countertop one it
matched the rest of the set of the thing
they took
you see what I'm saying usually above
the stove these days we have a big uh
rain a big uh vent okay all right really
really against me today for some
reason I'm trying not to be well you're
not trying hard enough this guy's
you don't think it's weird that
they took the microwave without running
a buy of hey FYI we're leaving
everything but we're taking the one
thing not a microwave I'm
thinking of I'm telling you that it's if
they took the oven yeah that'd be weird
it's the same thing not really
man not it's not it's uh okay well now
there's just a huge hole where the
microwave should go that's Desert Door
a door
is there a door that covers it no it's
like an exposed like you see now you see
the back of the wall it looks like
someone stole my microwave I
don't know what someone did that's what
it looks like so when you walked in and
it's jarring that like ugly here's
a fixture of the thing that is
completely gone and there's wires
sticking was there anything in there
that's weird to me was there anything in
the bill of sale that said that they
would leave the bill of sale or whatever
you have I don't know what they're
called no I don't receive
do you get a receipt
is there a receipt I don't like and not
like you went to the CVS uh there's they
gave me papers I haven't looked at bill
is sale did you get that from Django
Unchained no I don't know where I got it
from a bill of sale is a thing like the
call that's old school I think though
yeah here's your bill of sale like when
you're buying like oxen or something I
don't think that's like
no one's ever been like okay do you want
your bill of sale or do you want me to
throw it out the microwave was included
as a part of my dowry
uh
uh and just one moment please
everybody the microwave is missing yes
um yeah they jammed me up they stole my
my quave
um but it is what it is and I'll have to
find a new one yeah get a new one you
want a new one yeah I have to stop
saying that like I'm against you I have
to get into those people's microwave
what the who the short term so I could
use a microwave yes I got an extra one
if you want it you just told me not to
use someone else's microwave now you
want to give me like me
I'd rather use that guy's microwave
you're probably microwaving you're
undies and stuff in there
oh no way
yeah man she likes to heat it up a
little bit
just just fire it up we got to keep
these rents low man your place probably
smells beautiful in there we got the
pure and everything it's wonderful
man before right right now
what do we do though it's most beautiful
you're talking about microwaving
cat food what do I just okay I believe
that your your apartment smells you
don't smell fresh ever it's high-end cat
food though it actually smells kind of
good someone's got a stew cooking tartar
yeah the baby likes it she likes it
we'll heat it up a little bit nine
seconds boom chop it up give it to her
otherwise she can be a real problem huh
I know the feeling okay let's talk about
Adam and Eve shout out to it baby yeah
this episode is brought to you by Adam
and Eve whoo I'm hard as a rock baby
let's go how long you think Adam and
Eve's been in business I don't know five
years 50 years trusted Source they've
been making dudes jizm for 50
years that's a lot of dildos I'll tell
you that gang Adam and Eve's the
absolute best do yourself a favor spice
up things in the bedroom whether you're
with a partner or whether you're flying
solo baby it doesn't matter Adam and
Eve's got you covered yeah uh no matter
what you're into dildos butt plugs
Pocket spawners I got it all
whatever you're into not saying I'm into
that stuff but if you're I love it all
hit me up spice up with a partner check
out the selection of tools
um don't wait better sex is just a click
away take 50 off one item free shipping
with free Rush processing baby because
when you're charged up you ain't got
time to waste go to adamandeve.com
select any one item then enter the code
garbage at checkout this is an exclusive
offer for our listeners be sure to use
the code garbage to get your discount
100 free shipping and rust processing
that's adamandeve.com promo code garbage
adamandeve.com code garbage do it uh all
right this one's from scrotes McGraw
it's ten dollar shareholder shout out to
you all right this I we've talked we've
mentioned this and I think we fall on
different sides of this which we've been
doing all that man we've been button
head I know you've been not giving me
nothing
um scrotes My Goats scented trash bags
question mark
there's something not classy about I'm
not saying it's trash there's something
not it seems cheap which I enjoy it it
smells nice it seems cheap though I
think it's all-time worst product ever
invented I think it smells adorable it's
dog it makes it makes the trash
smell worse
it's the worst he's you're for it I
presume it smells like baby you're
against it it's lame it like
makes me sick to my stomach you know I I
totally I don't like the way they smell
coming out and I don't like this the way
they smell when uh you put them in when
trash when trash is in there sure it
that's it it reminds me of a baby's
diaper it smells like take that one
step further
I had to attend a uh social function uh
not that long ago
um outdoor little bar setting I don't
know who you think you are this episode
attending a social function not too long
ago outdoor bar okay you were drinking
beers in the street bill of sale yes
something you're real
highfalutin I don't think so
um telling me I can't use another guy's
microwave than offer to give me your
used microwave I was praying it was
pretty much brand new but not brand new
that's this is you it's Brandon pretty
much we only use it for a couple of
months when they were replacing ours
yeah so you've cooked hot cat
food in there daily for months I don't
want it I'd rather roll my dice with the
one they stole from me
so she tried to use the air fryer one
time well for a football for cat food
dude ah man I almost lost it
but yeah that's no going back right I
dropped it I dropped it in a fryer later
for two three minutes
hey ruined my mozzarella sticks what are
you talking about sauteing it throw that
pan out oh god
um anyway I was at a uh black tie affair
and uh they had the little bar set up
uh-huh you know what I mean like you
know just grab whatever you want they
had a cooler okay with beers and stuff
in it real black guys
hey you're on keg Duty next to that they
heard her roll the sleeves of your
tuxedo up when you're grabbing a bud
heavy next to that they had um
uh a like a Yeti cooler like a portable
cooler that had just ice in it okay
which I love a cooler with Justice sure
it to me it shows such Forward Thinking
yeah it goes hey we're killing it so so
bad so good we have a extra cooler we
don't even need for the party and we're
filling it with us well let me ask you
this I love it what if that wasn't there
and there was just the cooler with the
beers and the sodas and the waters in it
and then you wanted to just to make a
soda would you use that ice
would you use the cooling ice as a as
drinking ice like in the cooler in the
cooler sure yeah I mean surprised a lot
of a lot of hands going in there yeah I
don't I don't love it uh but uh yeah I
have for sure done that well here and
it's one of those I'm typically drinking
so I can get over it sure if I'm just
having a soda and I'm dead sober at a
party which I don't think has ever
happened
um you know it's whatever but if I'm
making a mixed drink on a if I'm
making a transfusion on a nice sunny day
down the shore ah my hand's going right
in that far I'm scooping her up so that
was nice that they had it however they
had the ice in a clean new trash bag oh
that was scented what yeah it must have
been an oversight that's a no-fly zone
yeah I took a sip of my diet Pepsi and
almost gag that'll kill you I
think it does That's like been
sick to my stomach ever since Dupont
chemicals that ain't good
yeah it's so we don't need it stop with
that I know everybody's buying up
everybody and you think that you know
you're giving us something better we're
buying up everybody you know Febreze has
got to work with glad and this one's got
to work with this one and this and that
and they're doing you know
Cinnabons and you really don't have
their big fragrance today watch out it's
just I tell you what you know you could
do make sure that the thing
doesn't rip when all of all's I do is
lightly grab the string do that
I don't need to smell nice just I needed
what happened remember when Hefty you
could drive a car through that thing
when he said lightly lift the string did
you imagine the biggest bag of trash
you've ever seen there's probably Sirens
going off saying please stop please stop
there you go more they always rip now
even the stretchy ones suck that's why I
like I go contractor bags heavy bike
yeah you got to be really you are
putting out Industrial Waste that's
right
special guys gotta come and get it
fresh Labs got to come pick that up
uh dude we had a dumpster dropped in
front of our house for a long time
growing up and man that was the best
just trash right in the driveway we did
it for months and months and months it
was great are they working on anything
slowly they were doing I think the
basement but then that wasn't happening
there was a there was a dumpster in my
driveway
man everybody comes out to watch that
thing get dropped oh yeah we had that we
had coal dumped I mean every year we'd
have cold dump because of the fireplace
we'd get wood dumped we get
mulch dumped man that was an afternoon
knowing that there was no way you were
gonna get to go inside until all that
mulch was the dreads in front of the
goddamn garage can't get the car out to
go to work today that's gotta go yeah I
would say it was so funny uh a couple
quarts of wood or whatever they call
them Cords Cord a cord of wood never
understood what that meant I knew it was
gonna ruin my Saturday yeah it's a unit
of measurement I don't know what it is
if it's pounded you're like you know
square foot square footage uh
I was just so funny you just brought
that up I was thinking yesterday we uh
of the uh those red stones those
little red stones my dad the one summer
redid All of the he had like a bunch of
flower bed or like you know
stones in the bed where mulch was yeah
so we had to get rid of the
mulch lay some like mat down you gotta
put like trash bags down yeah it was
like the plant uh the weed protector or
whatever that didn't work either we use
plastic we do we tried it in like the
next year I was like thank God that's
done he's like nah the weeds are
coming up we're using plastic bags pull
it all up hit all that dude and I'm
talking an everest-sized mountain of
that Redstone to the point where all
your boogies were Red by the end of the
day you were coughing up red Hawkers it
was base all that dust coming up you're
like spraying water on it oh my buddy
had a stone driveway like that the
trashiest every time you pulled out you
felt like one of the Duke boys
what are you doing she's got a mantle
laying Wheels getting out I tell you as
a fat lazy kid the one thing I hated the
most I'll rake the leaves I'll
about it I'll do the lawn picking
weeds sucked it feels like you're not
making any traction ever and then you
grab one of those ones with the
daggers on them God damn it
that'll make a heater feel real weird in
your hand
s fingers pulsing yeah you feel it swell
up you get tight yeah nah weeding
so I like and there's no ease
people like oh use the shot and it's
like no tool you just gotta use gotta
grab it and you're just and I
remember you look you do it for what
feels like an hour and a half and you've
covered one square foot and it
sucks get that round up in there
start thumping bleach I don't know what
happened
Patty uses salt now
which is she comes up with these crazy
remedies or things that don't work but
where the dogs go doo doo she she
doesn't want to put chemicals back there
um maybe children the out a little
bit uh she uses salt on the weeds
doesn't work dogs learn it somewhere or
something they're like probably that's
probably how you got the poison ivy on
your face
trying to lick the salt in the back yeah
Ma someone put a pound of salt back here
whatever trying to keep me out of the
cookies
she rubbed poison alcohol over the
Charlie's chips can maybe you had a beer
in one hand and a Sig in the other and
an itch on your face and you itched it
on a tree that's something I could see
you doing now I listen it was 30
something years ago 30 years ago oh this
is my Cold Case man yeah I don't know I
wasn't around anything we weren't in the
woods partying like that it was it
nobody could figure it out just poison
ivy oh you had Mensa on the case
though who's Mensa Mensa who's that it's
a protective group of very smart people
I'm saying you had a bunch of idiots
trying to figure it ain't you not Mensa
that's not that yes it is it's meant
because it's in uh
uh Me Myself and Irene it's Mensa Mensa
yeah you sure oh yeah m-e-n-s-a okay I
mean the irony of irony
um man you are something else today big
guy this guy's out in left field with a
hockey stick why would Mensa be
investigating a poison ivy case
that would be animal control or
something like that that's also they're
Mensa has a better animal control or the
Botanicals
Garden
it wouldn't be Mensa they have bigger
things to work on it would be a botanist
would be investigating yeah because they
got so much free time a forensic
botanist would be investigating okay
hear me out on this hear me out on this
hear me out on this you're stuck in a
hotel you're download you're you're down
the shore with Foley he eats all the
snacks the first night you're partying
so to get them back then this just
happened down the shore
so to get them back you go you grab some
poison ivy you come in you rub it on his
face while he's sleeping I think there
was Foul Play I think that was fat he
was an inside job I think you probably
didn't remember being in the woods or
Lambs Whedon or something yeah if I had
I mean it's it's I mean I don't think
there was any Foul Play I don't think
there was bigger uh bigger parties all
the way to the top
Mr sumac horsepower was on acid when it
started coming on all right it's
always another layer of the story brutal
I was in a k-hole for two weeks I don't
know what happened
freak you out man freak you out
he's so selective in the information he
shares
that's such a huge caveat sucks
I was working at a poison ivy farm for a
couple of weeks uh one more thing you're
you're the reverse Columbo uh one more
thing I don't know what psychedelics
have anything to do with it
ass and who knows what you were up to
who knows if there was even poison ivy
there was I went to that they dropped me
off at Shore Memorial and I got a
steroid you could have been it's
Mac and manko's pizza place for all you
know you're a all tripping I was
there the night before
I was there the night before I was at
Mac and Max and they they was right
before the season started and they
weren't happy that we were in there
we were all on acid
so
it gave us a real bad Vibe I still love
their Pizza though you can do whatever
they want to me sure Mac and Max man
you are throwing seven different
kinds of crazy today dude
I feel like I've been podcasting with
four different people already I don't
think so uh all right this one's from
doggy dingleberries uh use ever been on
fire
if you're in a bad situation if you have
been
that's a couple times yeah and every
once in a while one of those really hits
you's ever been on fire
he's ever been on fire he's ever
been on fire oh uh my shoe was one
time and out of a panic luckily was a
big fat skate shoe so I it was it came
off quick it wasn't real laced that well
and almost tough did you ever catch the
ice cream truck
if I was laying Wheels
you want to see hippie run real fast
how the did your shoe catch on fire
I think we were lighting a hacky sack on
fire and doing like a flaming hacky sack
type Circle wow yeah uh this is when we
were you know seventh eighth grade
smoking weed Hacky Sacks were
not cool but in I'll give you uh around
they were they were they were readily
available and we would like them on
everybody goes through a hacky stuff of
course I was terrible at it we would I
was okay we would light them on fire
and what was like you might know it's
like the uh uh it's like the
Challenger War you like hit it twice and
then you like try to Peg someone with it
yeah we call it knockout yeah something
like that you have to juggle it two or
three times when you're playing and then
you hit someone and if they don't catch
it then they're out we would do that and
everybody gets to slug them catch it in
their hand or with their no they have to
like control it and like keep the ball
like keep it in the air okay but after
two hits you wing it you
crank it at someone yeah that Soldier
and we get eliminated you gotta walk on
the circle everybody gets slug you in
the arm really okay yeah I've been on
fire on a number of times pants a bunch
I let my arm on fire for uh like a like
a sketch one time that was a good that
was a good one really just did some
light bumps the Flaming Bozo everybody
yeah I really did some light Googling my
buddy was like Mad TV I've been talking
about here my buddy was lubing my arm up
and I was like you know what you're
doing right he's like I watched like 40
seconds of a YouTube tutorial there's
always one or two of those guys on
America's Got Talent yeah some kid out
there singing his heart and the guy just
walks out on fire yeah it's like how you
gonna top that brake fluid is what you
use because it the the gas like you're
telling me like I'm gonna try oh why do
you say tell me earlier T-Bone
brake fluid and orange juice because the
it's just the gas catches on fire not
the actual liquid so it goes out pretty
easy but it's a big flame
thanks scuzzball yeah what the more
with amateur uh stuntman uh it's
crazy that Red Bull doesn't sponsor me
because you lit yourself on fire once
that seems pretty good no one saw it
what kind of spokesman is it one time no
one saw me be an idiot no that video was
on ifc.com about nine clicks from the
homepage there you go deep in the
cavernous
cavernous backlogged
um
I bit my coat with a cigarette one time
I was all cooked up I can bump my
uh I was uh yeah the Flaming uh
the shoe that I think that was it any
like actual real Panic of but fire
scares me I really Panic around it sure
really Panic it's not my cup of
tea would you ever jump over a fire we
did do that like we would set like uh
there was like bike tracks oh yeah their
bike sure I never fell into it that's
one thing I don't think we ever talked
about the bike jumps that just existed
in the woods from previous generations
yes dude we made who made them and what
happened to them I don't know man there
was just like your older brother's
friends would go because they heard from
their older brothers and they were just
in the woods for 30 years they existed
it's probably since the 80s when I was
going in the 2000s that's nuts
and they're everywhere all over the
country all over the country and you go
in there like a like a geographical
Explorer like you're you're pulling
bushes aside overgrown you're bringing
it back to life it's like a lost city
yeah it's a Jurassic Park uh-huh
man I remember through the we found one
one summer and it was like good
we like heard rumors of it so we went
down to get eyes on it there was like
one kid that knew from somebody where it
was yeah
yeah and then you found it
and that's what there was like a small
set of doubles like a double jump and we
lit a fire in it after like we just
spent every did we'd wake up in the
morning get on our bikes go there for uh
14 hours a day
and by like the fifth day we were all
like you know real Pro like knew
the core because this was like a course
a little bit you know sure and we take
shovels we build it up the parts that
got like worn down by the water or
whatever man what do you say we get out
of here and hit some jumps years of
neglect
deforestation bring it all back
it's a good time ah it's all right
um all right let's do one or two more
and then we gotta get going near gang
um this one's from Taylor is it garbage
if you pass out at your own party wake
up the next morning the hot tubs filled
with Bernie say hi to Tony for me uh
uh post is a tough look because no one
then gives a no one cares unless
they're like you're real tight homie
yeah like I wouldn't your house up
but like if I'm at a house then I'm like
oh who's this the Toby it's that guy
sleeping on the couch I'm like we're
cranking heaters in here I'm getting
making a sandwich making a sandwich yeah
we're doing it oh man and that's like
that's the one time in a sea of mundane
partying that the wildest will have
happened you'll wake up and it'll be
like dude Johnny hung dong they
got the whipped cream out it was a scene
bro and every other time it's like ah we
had some beers and you know watch
DVD box out of 24. no one
responded to my text message I always
felt like I missed the good parties
where good happens always the ones
that I was like I think it's there's
very this is my take as somebody who's
done a lot of boozing right it's very
rarely that cool does happen most
of the nights are relatively the same
you know what I mean it's like you're
getting up it's the same handful
of guys same group of girls same
whatever you're going to the same bars
the cops would only show up every once
in a while and they were usually the fun
ones that was crazy yeah everybody run
the scatter that's good but like that
was once a year maybe and like you know
those were bigger party like that that
stuff was like established of like
so-and-so's having a big to do
type thing but I mean it's pretty much
the same
same I've been drinking the same beers
smoking the same things quoting Seinfeld
for the last 15 years it's all right
though
ain't too bad not too shabby uh this
one's from Roy ever put a full face
helmet on there just to get hit in the
head with stuff
that's all right
I guess like a catcher's helmet or
something or like a race like a
motorcycle helmet I know we had uh
somebody's brother played hockey
remember remember the rubber the tan
rubber ones they were like the shitty
ones maybe street hockey ones the
helmets or the the legs the legs oh yeah
I had them yeah we put those on and like
a catchers Mitten a bunch of stuff to
not play sport oh yeah just just to hurt
each other oh yeah chairs poles
everything Wiffle ball bats yeah we uh
we got like my brother got a go-kart and
he had like the full face like
motorcycle helmet just like a generic
glass oh when you got your hands on a
motorcycle helmet as a kid you might as
well thought we were in the back
of somebody's garage you might have
thought we were running tests on you
know for safety protocol for cars dude
we were we had like no we're like
tracking data how you know did it did
that hurt no all right let's crank it up
a little bit
next thing next thing you make an
aluminum bat out
really getting after it that's all right
well we gotta wrap it up gang gang we
love you to death oh yeah second show
added in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
December 20th December 20th come out and
see us at the Fillmore you get your
tickets at rugarbage.com already sold
that one let's sell out two babies close
out the year strong also all the other
dates are there on the website added
some second shows some third shows in a
couple of places but not everywhere so
do yourself a favor and get your tickets
now we love you to death and we'll see
you next week